the u.s has long led the world in the
number of children
sentenced to life in prison without the
possibility of parole
in one state pennsylvania has put more
juveniles behind bars for life than
anywhere else in the country
of those people joe lagun has the tragic
distinction of being the oldest
and longest-serving juvenile lifer in
the country
he was recently released from a
pennsylvania prison
after 68 years cbs this morning saturday
co-host michelle miller
spoke with le gunn in his first
television interview since his release
michelle good morning
good morning joe liggin was released
from prison back in february
after a series of u.s supreme court
decisions found that
those mandatory life without parole
sentences for juveniles were
unconstitutional
this highlights the issues of over
sentencing
in america's criminal justice system and
for ligand
now a free man he's entering a world
a modern world he barely knows
what was the first thing you did as a
free man i almost cried
okay but i broke down with a big smile
on my face
a free man free at last
83 year old joe liggin was released from
prison last month after serving nearly
seven
decades for crimes he committed when he
was 15.
ligand the son of alabama sharecroppers
was incarcerated
when dwight d eisenhower was president
good evening my fellow americans and nat
king cole's pretend
was on the music charts yeah those buses
there
they didn't exist whenever because they
had street street
he returns to a changed world i looked
at one and seen all these high buildings
but i expect to see that they locked me
up they did
they didn't lock my mind up in 1953
ligand and four other black teenagers
were involved in an alcohol-fueled spree
of robberies
and stabbings in philadelphia two people
died
what were you guilty of i was guilty
with
being at the wrong place at the wrong
time it wasn't with the intention of
hurting nobody i didn't murder anybody
there are people out there who are going
to watch and they're going to say
he stabbed someone he committed a crime
you say to them what i'm sorry
that i admitted a crime
i'm sorry that someone was murdered i'm
sorry about that
liggin concedes he did stab someone that
night
but maintains he didn't kill anyone he
says
he's a changed man did you feel remorse
for what you did yes i did
yes i did i had to feel remorse the
teenagers were tried together
it was a city hall when you were tried
yeah that's what they told me
they pleaded guilty and were convicted
of two counts of first degree murder
and sentenced to life in prison with no
chance
of ever getting out this is the heaviest
petition i filed
public defender bradley bridge has
represented ligand for more than
15 years i sensed there was an injustice
i felt compelled to do something about
it so
why was joe convicted joe was convicted
largely by guilt by association there
were four kids that were tried together
and a lot of the evidence against one
child was considered against the other
two or three other children
if this case went forward to trial today
he'd probably be found guilty
of a manslaughter charge and maybe a
third-degree murderer might do five to
ten or ten to twenty
ligand's niece valerie came to our
interview because
she wants to show the world liggin has a
supportive family
yeah she told me she tell me all the
stories
his fate started to change in 2016 when
the u.s supreme court ruled that
all juvenile lifers should have a chance
to be re-sentenced
but after nearly seven decades behind
bars
ligand refused to be released on parole
because he didn't want to be
supervised for the rest of his life so
they kept fighting
until a federal judge recently vacated
his sentence
he was released without parole you're
free outright
outright thank you jesus does joe's case
symbolize
what's wrong with the criminal justice
system first of all it symbolizes that
we really
should sentence people individually
based on who they are
and what it was that they did so a
mandatory sentence
doesn't do that and the second thing is
that children are particularly unique
in their ability to grow change and
reform themselves
and therefore giving an adult sentence
to a child is inherently wrong
the world may have changed most of his
immediate family
is long gone but joe liggins says he's
not dwelling on the past nothing i can
do about japan but the only thing i can
say
i just hope i have a better future and
consider this
it cost the state of pennsylvania 3
million dollars to
incarcerate joe liggin for those 68
years and that's without
any medical costs gail boy michelle
listen we all think you should be
punished when you commit a crime but we
also say the punishment should fit the
crime
in that case it doesn't seem to have
done that i'm glad he's out michelle
thank you very much for that story